got a very deep father-son relationship
movie yes very yeah dramatic dramatic
turn dramatic and your acting is
terrific and the it's it's this great
ensemble cast and it's serious and it's
moving it premieres tomorrow uh 4 20
April 20th yes which has its own
significance as you know was that
something that they're doing I mean are
they are they related in any way or is
it a total accident I don't I don't know
I think it's an accident I think it's a
happy accident I mean I know people
um have a tendency to imbibe on the uh
you know the uh the Jazz cigarette if
you will uh before watching films yeah
or television but uh but yeah no I think
this is a good this is a good uh movie
for that I mean you don't want to smoke
like a sativa beforehand I I feel like
maybe an indica or a hybrid would
probably be better suited see I didn't
yeah and you were like you were like a
sommelier with yeah yeah yeah with these
things I don't know I am very ignorant
about uh marijuana and things popular
yeah sure bud no no
yeah man me too man no I'm into the
pills man
I'm not sure
up I knock off pharmacies at night
that's what I need I need me pills man
no but uh I really don't know so I don't
know what's the difference like sativa
is how do you know the difference is
there an easy way for me to remember so
I seem hip and cool yeah yeah yeah uh
well I mean I I'd always heard I
remember hearing ages ago
um that Indica was like in the couch
like you know it like knocks you out
okay so like sativa would be if you were
going to um say like a jungle gym with
uh people from um Cirque du Soleil
you want to smoke a sativa you know
because you want to be up for that well
that and also they're gonna do crazy
and you want to watch that you know
like that's and you want to be you want
to laugh about that and giggle with them
and they're all speaking French and it's
going to be nuts so then hybrid hybrid
is like if you're going to like the same
jungle gym with like uh elderly you know
because you want to have your wits about
you in case you know someone breaks a
hip or something and um so that was yeah
it's the same exactly yeah so so it's a
nice and then Indica would be like if
you just wanted to go down the slide and
melt into it and like you know or play
in the balls like at McDonald's or
something and just sleep that's
something people do they go they get
high and they go in the bin of balls I
ask your audience
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's no vowels in there